Supervised and unsupervised learning are two corecomponents in building machine learning models.
So what's the difference?
Well, just to cut to the chase:
supervised learning, that uses labeled input
and output data,
while an unsupervised learning model doesn't.
But what does that really mean?
Well, let's better define both learning models,
go deeper into the differences between them
andthen answer the question of which is best for you.
Now, in supervised learning,the machine learning algorithm istrained on a labeled dataset.
So this meansthat each example in the training dataset, the algorithm knows what the correct output is.
And the algorithm uses this knowledge to try to generalize to new examples that it's never seenbefore.
Now, using labeled inputs and outputs, the model can measure its accuracy and learn overtime.
Supervised learning can be actually divided into a couple of subcategories.
Firstly,there is a category of classification.
And classification talks about whether the outputis a discrete class label
such as "spam" and "not spam".
Linear classifiers, support vectormachines, or SPMs, decision trees, random forests -
they're all common examples of classificationalgorithms.
The other example is regression.
The output here is a continuousvalue, such as price or probability.
Linear regression and logistic regression aretwo common types of regression algorithms.
Now, unsupervised learning is where the machinelearning algorithm is not really given any labelsat all.
And these algorithms discover hiddenpatterns in data without the need for human intervention.
They're unsupervised.
Unsupervised learning models are used for three main tasks, such as clustering, association and dimensionalityreduction.
So let's take a look at each one of those, starting with clustering.
Now clusteringis where the algorithm groups similar experiences together.
So a common application ofclustering is customer segmentation,
where businesses might group customers togetherbased on similarities like,
I don't know, age or location or spending habits, somethinglike that.
Then you have association.
And association is where the algorithm looksfor relationships between variables in the data.
Now association rules are often used in marketbasket analysis,
where businesses want to knowwhich items are often bought together.
You know,something along the lines of, "customers who boughtthis item also bought ",  that sort of thing.
The final one to talk about is dimensional ...
dimensional reduction.
And this is where thealgorithm reduces the number of variables in the data,
while still preserving as much ofthe information as possible.
Now, often this technique is used in the pre-processing datastage,
such as when autoencoders remove noisefrom visual images to improve picture quality.
Okay, so let's talk about the differences between these two types of learning.
In supervisedlearning, the algorithm learns from training datasets by iteratively making predictions on thedata
and then adjusting for the correct answer.
While supervised learning models tend to bemore accurate than unsupervised learning models,
they do require all of this up-front humanintervention to label the data appropriately.
For example, a supervised learning modelcan predict how long your commute will be
on the time of day and thinking aboutthe weather conditions and so forth.
But first you'll have to train it to know thingslike rainy weather extends the driving time.
By contrast, unsupervised learning models workon their own to discover the inherent structureof unlabeled data.
These models don't needhumans to intervene.
They can automatically find patterns in data and group them together.
So, for example, an unsupervised learning model can cluster images by the objects they contain
- things like people and animals and buildings -
without being told what those objects were aheadof time.
Now, an important distinction to make is that unsupervised learning models don't makepredictions.
They only group data together.
So if you were to use an unsupervised learning modelon that same commute dataset,
it would group together commutes with similar conditions
like the time of day and the weather,
but it wouldn't be able to predict how long eachcommute would take.
Okay, so which of these twooptions is right for you?
In general, supervisedlearning is more commonly used than unsupervised learning,
and that's really because it's moreaccurate and efficient.
But that being said, unsupervised learning has its own advantages.There's two that I can think of.
Firstly, unsupervised learning can be used on data that isnot labeled,
which is often the case in real world datasets.
And then secondly, unsupervised learningcan be used to find hidden patterns in data that supervised learning models just wouldn't find.
Classifying big data can be a real challenge in supervised learning, but the results are highlyaccurate and trustworthy.
And in contrast, unsupervised learning can handle large volumesof data in real time.
But there's a lack of transparency into how that data is clustered anda high risk given accurate results.
But wait, it is not an "either/or" choice.
May I presentto you the middle ground known as semi-supervised learning.
This is, well, a happy medium whereyou use a training data set with both labeled and unlabeled data.
And it's particularly useful whenit's difficult to extract relevant features from data when you have a high volume of data.
So, for example, you could use a semi-supervised learning algorithm on a data set with millions ofimages
where only a few thousand of those imagesare actually labeled.
Semi-supervisedlearning is ideal for medical images, where a small amount of training data could leadto a significant improvement in accuracy.
For example, a radiologist can look at and label somesmall subset of CT scans for tumors or diseases,
and then the machine can more accuratelypredict which patients might require more medical attention
without going throughand labeling the entire set.
Machine learning models are a powerful way to gainthe data insights that improve our world.
The right model for your data depends on thetype of data that you have and what you want to do with it.
And the choice between supervised andunsupervised learning is only the first step.
If you have any questions, please drop us a line below.
And if you want to see more videos like this in the future, please like and subscribe.
Thanks for watching!